[Musique]
on reproche souvent à facebook de
propager de fausses nouvelles mais le
réseau social se veut proactif en ce qui
concerne le coronavirus les autorités
sanitaires le répète pour éviter la
panne et qu'il faut partager les faits
dire la vérité
c'est pourquoi facebook part à la chasse
des théories du complot qui pullulent
sur ses pages et va éliminer toute
publication erronées sur le coved 19 ou
sur les produits qu'on présente comme
des remèdes miracles entreprises offrent
d'ailleurs gratuitement des espaces
publicitaires à l' agence mondiale la
santé et présentent des liens vers les
agences sanitaires officielles
mais facebook lui aussi participé aux
recherches internationales pour
comprendre les mécanismes de propagation
du virus
pour y arriver facebook à utiliser les
données personnelles des membres qui
seront agrégés et rendues anonymes
[Musique]